now i have a very special guest alan
sakyan here who's we have to make him
wait but
hopefully this will be rewarding
asking deep questions taps into the soul
of another person
and connects each other in phenomenal
ways a true
physical experience today we have
someone who we know can help you ask
deeper questions in your daily life
and unleash your unique gifts alan
sakyan is the founder and host
of the simulation podcast where he
interviews some of the most creative
scientists
entrepreneurs and educators of our time
allen has worked with ted to create the
tedx talk the art of powerful questions
and his youtube channel simulation has
over 10 million views
allen's goal is to actualize the wildly
unique gifts in each one of us
and maximize human potential thank you
so much alin for being here with us
today
thanks for having me abeed and what fun
it's been attending
what you guys have been sharing i've
been learning so much
from you guys it's been great
good to hear and to connect kind of to
our theme of
uh deep questions you have done an
interview with lisa best lacrosse on
superpower you and she asked you what
your superpower was
and you said uh asking deep questions
can you remember the first moment when
this gift
kind of showed itself perhaps in
childhood or teen years
cool one of my favorite quotes is
from tony robbins he says the quality of
your life is the quality of your
questions
and
i remember always being fascinated by
understanding who we are
why we're here and just
asking these questions around what the
nature of reality is
what consciousness is and
being able to share the wisdoms that we
gain from the big questions with
the rest of society and then
maximize the blossoming and the full
potential of what
it looks like when every single one of
us is
actualizing our gifts and there's
widespread
abundance for everybody
and so it really starts
in your years in these youthful years
of honing in on why is it so important
for me to ask the biggest possible
questions that i can formulate
and not only for myself individually
and actualize my own fullest potential
but
for the potential of my family and for
the community and for the world at large
so it's yeah really interesting that it
started at a young age
asking the biggest questions and when
you do have a deep conversation
with somebody on your podcast
that connection you have like the
physical the feeling
why do you think that's more important
and why do you think we most of us just
stick to the surface level
uh boring ones in our day-to-day lives
so it's like a gym repetition
so you might start off with five
pounds and then work your way up to 10
and then 15
and so you build strength another
analogy for it is
a submarine which i referenced in the
tedx talk
and so staying at the surface level is
going to yield you
very surface level rewards but diving
into the depths
of the most difficult questions to
formulate and ask
and then also to
be able to maintain the relationship
with the person that you're asking the
question to
while you ask those big questions is
more difficult but it yields you greater
fruits
so when you
are typically in the
phase of being in surface level
questions
your gym repetition or you're diving the
submarine deeper
then surface level typically has to do
with rather than
asking a question about
something around the weather or around
sports or around entertainment or around
the news
instead ask a question
that is about the person's goals
or the person's ambitions or about one
of the most powerful
lessons that they've experienced in
their life
or about their familial history
or about why why they think their
even in this world
and in doing so those questions are
harder to ask
they're harder to engage with the other
person
but over time you build up the muscle
with these gym repetitions
and your submarine ends up diving deeper
and deeper
into the
more difficult essence
of what it means to be human so i highly
encourage
that
analogy of repetitions and i think you
started lifting
these question asking weights when you
were doing those street interviews
with your mic and camera and you went up
to strangers and asked them questions
and so when i see that allen back then
or even episode one of simulation and
now at episode
762 um uh how are those two allens
different
yeah such a good question six years
so yeah in 2015 it was
practice happy taking a camera and a mic
on the streets and just asking people
what makes you happy
or what impact you want to make in the
universe what was the last thing you did
that scared
you if you could tell your younger self
one thing what would it be
which is also something that you guys
mentioned
and
the fearlessness is another big thing
like you guys mentioned being
unafraid is such a big big part of it
so there will be times when it's more
difficult
because the other person is feeling
like a contraction and that they want to
reject
you the question that's being asked and
so
you deal with all different types of
energetic responses to your questions
and so over the period of six years it's
the process of dealing
with all of these different thousands of
interactions with humans
and sensing that spectrum of energetic
difference between something that's very
contracted and closed off
versus something that's very open and
willing to share
and
a lot of what my questions were about
six years ago
were and even when we were first
starting simulation
were questions around
the most cutting cutting-edge sciences
the most
unique insights around entrepreneurship
and business
the biggest political questions
and then slowly they became more
metaphysical
so the questions became more around
consciousness and more around the nature
of reality
who are we why are we even here
and so that was really fruitful because
as you dive into the questions that are
around
those essences you gain
deeper and deeper insight into
who you truly are and who we
are as a collective and why we're even
here
and then that empowers everything that
you do it empowers you it empowers
your relationship with your family your
relationship with your loved ones
with your friends with your classmates
with the world and with your
unique gift that you're bringing forth
because you start feeling a greater
sense of unity you start feeling a
greater sense of
oneness you start feeling not only the
oneness with
the environment and the planet but you
start feeling the oneness with each
other
at a deeper level so the same unity that
you feel with your
family members you start expressing that
same
unconditional love unity to your friends
and to the world at large and then that
is infused into everything you
create from then on and so that's
really the big shift that's happened in
the last six years
for me is now being able to really
infuse
the essence of unity and oneness
into everything that i do and
because of asking those big questions
and getting to the bottom of the truth
now it was started from
questions to now really like a life
purpose
and something you brought up our oneness
and unity
was said exactly by dean nelson a
journalist we had interviewed
who had 40 years of experience and he
said it's to explore our shared humanity
and when those things i heard they
really did click
and i wanted to ask you this what if
everyone had
deep conversations like uh the janitors
at school
or a bus driver or a family at the
dinner table
um all around the world everybody has a
deep conversation
what would that world look like
i love it so
in order for us to have that world
the core component
that i've noticed is that we have to be
willing to drop
the wall that we put up between
one another so
i mentioned this earlier as well
where sometimes when you ask someone a
deeper question
there will be resistance to answering
because there won't be
so much of that open-hearted
vulnerability
and not only around
if you ask someone a question around hey
what do you think the purpose of the
universe is and they're like
oh i don't know and sometimes people
you know feel that closed-offness
but also around you know what is the
deepest
trauma or the deepest wound that you've
experienced or that your family has
experienced you know
questions like that as well people put
up the wall oh i don't know you i'm not
going to answer that question
and so this is this is the one thing the
most
core component is learning how to drop
the wall
because of that unity and that oneness
is that abede is not asking me this
question
in order to create some sort of harm for
me or my family
but instead of beed is asking this
question out of that shared unity
out of that shared oneness out of the
exploration
and out of a more playful a more
childlike
essence and when we recognize that
that this wall of separation begins to
dissolve more and more
and i begin feeling more of that
open-hearted vulnerability
and unconditional love and that enables
us to have these deeper conversations
and then we practice these more
thought-provoking questions
and we get to deeper and deeper levels
of our
essence
deeper part of our essence that's
spectacular words
and you really did say once um
interconnectedness is the root of all
our problems
and really if if the world had just done
deep conversations with everyone and
every time
that would be one check off the list
and asking deep questions is one of your
gifts and you've pursued them
furiously for over six years to
actualize them with such passion and
hard work
uh yet this gifts is kind of like an
uncommon concept for us
how do you think as high schoolers is
this a period of time where we can start
to see them surface
or how can we recognize them
abeed one more time with the question
four
high schoolers how can you yeah
how can you go ahead how can we
recognize the gifts we're
uniquely blueprinted for oh
oh what a great question okay
okay so
the number one thing that i've learned
around this
is the the feeling
it's like an energetic attraction so
if you have a big buffet of options
let's say that you have a little bit of
biology
and you have a little bit of track
and field and then you have a little bit
of computer science
and you have a little bit of art and
music
right you're starting to sample
several different items on the buffet
now maybe you begin feeling a stronger
gravitational attraction
to art and music and maybe
specifically in that you like
especially the guitar let's say and then
in biology
what really interests you is the
the biotech aspect maybe you like the
idea of
engineering and biology so to figure out
the
subtle nuances of cells and how to
reprogram them for longevity
right so now you're now you're more
sensitive to the specific
aspects of the full buffet of
options that you're gravitated towards
and then i would double down on those
specific
areas does that make sense guys
cool and and feel free to continue
also exploring while you do that
so even if you get into biotech and
guitar
because you're gonna get older in three
years what you might do is
you might you know carolyn might meet up
with justin
and justin might be like hey i've been
studying this new
aspect of of figuring out how to
maximize the potential of of india and
their one point almost five billion
person population
and we could potentially accelerate the
nonprofit work there or what have you
and so carolyn might become interested
in that
because justin opened up the option on
the buffet
so always remember that there will be
new options on the buffet that are
opened
and for you to kind of keep feeling into
that
as well
cool i feel like that analogy was
resonant
good good as and you talked about this
just this feeling like a phenomenal
feeling you get
when you gravitate towards something why
is it important
to double down on these things is it for
a future reward or
yeah yeah good question
so one of the core
aspects about being human
is that and i noticed that on the
little boards that you guys were
showcasing earlier that one of the core
skills that you had learned was
meditation
and so you'll learn to become
more and more present
and you'll learn the beauty of
when you're present you know a bead you
were expressing the importance of
active listening right you're basically
meditating
on the present moment non-stop
so like it becomes like every moment of
life becomes
divine and you become you
infuse your unconditional love with
every moment of life
and so when you gain that style of
meditative
infusion of unconditional love into
every moment of your life
you also realize that there's this
future and what we've been doing for a
long period of time
for thousands of years is we've been
figuring out how to make
sacrifices in the present
for the future and so if you imagine the
future
is like a big north star
and let's say you're picking up the in
our example earlier from the buffet you
are picking up a little bit of
the art and music with maybe the guitar
and a little bit of biology with
cellular engineering
and now what you're doing is you're
beginning to envision the star
and in the star position you might be
like okay
well i'm interested in performing
with the guitar maybe once a month
at a local venue and creating an album
on spotify
by the end of the year and on cellular
engineering
i'm interested in attending a
biohacking group that is in my local
area
once a week and then building projects
with them
and so now what you're doing is you're
taking what
is in the north star position which are
these goals
within the fields that you've begun
feeling that resonance with as well as
how you're
you're infusing unconditional love into
every single
divine moment of your life through
all of the rollercoaster ups and downs
you're still infusing unconditional love
and you're noticing that what you're
doing is in the present
you're negotiating you're sacrificing
for example a bead is gonna message me
and abed's gonna say hey why don't you
come out with me
to this new movie premiere
but it's it's landing on the same
day that i have to go to the biohacking
group
and so you have to figure out how to
negotiate
[Music]
this potential short-term gratification
of things like i'm going to go out and
go to a movie with some of my friends or
i'm going to
go out and have lunch or dinner with
some of my friends
versus i have the star and i have this
vision for the future where i have an
album that's published by the end of the
year
and in order for me to get that album
published i actually
have to attend to the music production
skills that i'm learning right now and
so you feel more and more of that
that sacrifice
of what is in the short term
for what is in this north star long-term
position
someone who's read your high-level
perception book you explained that so
clearly and with such perfect examples
writing everyone to perfectly understand
how important it is to really
push push towards those interests and
experiences that really gravitate uh
people gravitate towards
you had interviews with public education
experts
like carol kovachar and esther wojcicki
and they had very interesting takes on
education and really how to raise a
successful youth
and if you could go back to your high
school self
and you know like hold them by the
shoulder and tell them a few words
is there anything that you would tell
them to do differently
no nope
that's the beauty of it is that you're
everything that you're going through
right now each and every one of you
is perfect exactly as it is
exactly as it is so you're getting
exactly the perfect amount of
your own figuring out life
at the same time that your family is
maybe creating some pressures
meanwhile you're meeting some new
friends meanwhile your teachers are
teaching you some things
meanwhile we're having this conversation
you're getting the exact right dose of
all of the catalysts that are needed
all the influences that are needed
and all of you figuring out your life
right now
so for example if i let's say could go
back
right now and try and grab myself by the
shoulders from
10 years ago i actually couldn't deliver
something to me that would
influence me because
i'm exactly prepared
perfectly for the trajectory that i'm
going on at that exact time
so if you could go back and say
something it would be like
keep it up keep up the good work
we're all counting on you we're all
proud of you we all love you
you're enough exactly as you are
and you're headed towards a beautiful
future
and just to know that you are loved
exactly as you are
and you're headed towards a beautiful
future
thank you what a spectacular message
to end off this with and such an
enriching interview
love and hope for our unity and sharing
in humanity
and i really whenever you speak when i
was
researching for my interviews you are
genuinely someone
um in the future whose name i'd like to
hear more often
and your stories your clear purpose and
thoughts are
a guide for youth thanks salman it's
wonderful that you say these things
you guys have been such a pleasure what
a cool
secondary school you guys are and
i'm really appreciated sitting through
your presentations and your explorations
of
interviewing and conversations and these
unique aspects that
you have to practice in order to dive
deep
into the deeper truths
of the human essence and that shared
unity that shared oneness and maximizing
prosperity for everybody
i feel that energy in your
secondary school emanating and thank you
for the opportunity to come and share
and to learn from you as well
everybody huh
thank you you guys are so sweet